hey everyone welcome back to the channel
today we're diving into the world of
onion growing and I'll be showing you
how to plant onion sets specifically
Shakespeare and centu yellow varieties
plus we'll be experimenting with two
different gardening methods a no dig bed
versus hul culture we're going to see
which one grows better onions so let's
get started so today is the 5th of OCT
October and it's the perfect time to
plant these onion sets I'm planting two
different varieties Shakespeare and
centu yellow these are Hardy
overwintering onions which means they'll
grow through the colder months and be
ready to harvest in early summer next
year when planting onion sets I'm making
sure each one is placed about 5 cm deep
you'll want to space them about 10 CM
apart and leave about 20 cm between the
rows this gives the onions plenty of
space to grow without competing for
nutrients first up I'm planting in this
no dig bed as the name suggests there's
no digging involved the idea here is to
build up the soil Naturally by layering
compost Mulch and other organic
materials directly on top of the ground
this protects the so soil structure and
encourages earthworms and other
beneficial organisms to do their thing
over time this method improves soil
Health without disturbing it it's a
simple low effort way to Garden we'll
see how it compares to our next method
next we have the hul Coter bed hul Coter
is a German term that means Mound
culture and it's a raised bed technique
that uses decaying wood branches and
organic matter as the base the idea is
that as the wood breaks down it releases
nutrients and retains moisture this
method can be really great for water
conservation especially in drier
climates this bed should break down
slowly over time providing a
nutrient-rich environment for our onions
it'll be interesting to see if this
method gives us better results compared
to the no dig bed that the onion sets
are planted in both the no dig and hul
culture beds it's time to let nature
take its course normally I'd water them
in after planting but today the ground
is already pretty wet so I'll just rake
over the soil and leave it as is now
it's just a waiting game to see which
method performs better will the no dig
bed come out on top or will hugle
culture prove to be the winner only time
will tell thanks for joining me on this
onion planting Adventure I'll be sure to
update you as the onions grow so don't
forget to subscribe if you want to
follow along leave a comment below if
you've tried either of these methods or
have any tips for growing onions see you
in the next video and happy gardening